We have introduced the concept
of expected value or mean,
which tells us the average value
of a random variable.
We will now introduce another
quantity, the variance, which
quantifies the spread of the
distribution of a random variable.
So consider a random variable
with a given PMF, for example
like the PMF shown
in this diagram.
And consider another random
variable that happens to have
the same mean, but
it's distribution
is more spread out.
So both random variables have
the same mean, which we denote
by mu, and which in this picture
would be somewhere
around here.
However, the second PMF, the
blue PMF, has typical outcomes
that tend to have a larger
distance from the mean.
By distance from the mean what
we mean is that if the result
of the random variable, its
numerical value, happens to
be, let's say for example, this
one, then this quantity
here is X minus mu is the
distance from the mean, how
far away the outcome of the
random variable happens to be
from the mean of that
random variable.
Of course, the distance from the
mean is a random quantity.
It is a random variable.
Its value is determined once
we know the outcome of the
experiment and the value
of the random variable.
What can we say about the
distance from the mean.
Let us calculate its average
or expected value.
The expected value of the
distance from the mean, which
is this quantity, using the
linearity of expectations, is
equal to the expected value of
X minus the constant mu.
But the expected value is by
definition equal to mu.
And so we obtain zero.
So we see that the average value
of the distance from the
mean is always zero.
And so it is uninformative.
What we really want is the
average absolute value of the
distance from the mean, or
something with this flavor.
Mathematically, it turns out
that the average of the
squared distance from the
mean is a better behaved
mathematical object.
And this is the quantity
that we will consider.
It has a name.
It is called the variance.
And it is defined as the
expected value of the squared
distance from the mean.
The first thing to note is that
the variance is always
non-negative.
This is because it is the
expected value of non-negative
quantities.
How exactly do we computer
the variance?
The squared distance from the
mean is really a function of
the random variable X. So it is
a function of the form g of
X, where g is a particular
function defined this way.
So we can use the expected value
rule applied to this
particular function g.
And we obtain the following.
So what we have to do is to go
over all numerical values of
the random variable X. For
each one, calculate its
squared distance from the mean
and weigh that quantity
according to the corresponding
probability of that particular
numerical value.
One final comment, the variance
is a bit hard to
interpret, because it is
in the wrong units.
If capital X corresponds to
meters, then the variance has
units of meters squared.
A more intuitive quantity is
the square root of the
variance, which is called
the standard deviation.
It has the same units as the
random variable and captures
the width of the distribution.
Let us now take a quick look at
some of the properties of
the variance.
We know that expectations have
a linearity property.
Is this the case for the
variance as well?
Not quite.
Instead we have this relation
for the variance of a linear
function of a random variable.
Let us see why it is true.
We use the shorthand notation
mu for the expected value of
X. We will proceed one step at a
time and first consider what
happens to the variance
if we add the
constant to a random variable.
So let Y be X plus
some constant b.
And let us just define nu to
be the expected value of Y,
which, using linearity of
expectations, is the expected
value of X plus b.
Let us now calculate
the variance.
By definition the variance of Y
is the expected value of the
distance squared of
Y from its mean.
Now we substitute, because
in this case Y is
equal to X plus b.
Whereas the mean, nu,
is mu plus b.
And now we notice that this
b cancels with that b.
And we are left with the
expected value of X minus mu
squared, which is just the
variance of X. So this proves
this relation for the case
where a is equal to 1.
The variance of X plus b is
equal to the variance of X. So
we see that when we add a
constant to a random variable,
the variance remains
unchanged.
Intuitively, adding a constant
just moves the entire PMF
right or left by some
amount, but without
changing its shape.
And so the spread of this
PMF remains unchanged.
Let us now see what happens if
we multiply a random variable
by a constant.
Let again nu be the expected
value of Y. And so in this
case by linearity this is equal
to a times the expected
value of X. So it
is a times mu.
We calculate the variance once
more using the definition and
substituting in the place of
Y what Y is in this case--
it's aX--
and subtracting the mean of
Y, which is a mu, squared.
We take out a factor
of a squared.
And then we use linearity of
expectations to note that this
is a squared times the expected
value of X minus mu
squared, which is a squared
times the variance of X.
So this establishes this formula
for the case where b
equals zero.
Putting together these two
facts, if we multiply a random
variable by a, the variance gets
multiplied by a squared.
And if we add a constant, the
variance doesn't change.
And this establishes this
particular fact.
As an example, the variance of,
let's say, 3 minus 4X is
going to be equal minus 4
squared times the variance of
X, which is 16 times
the variance of X.
Finally, let me mention an
alternative way of computing
variances, which is often
a bit quicker.
We have this useful
formula here.
We will see later a few examples
of how it is used,
but for now let me just
show why it is true.
We have by definition that the
variance of X is the expected
value of X minus mu squared.
Now let us rewrite what is
inside the expectation by just
expanding this square, which
is [X squared minus]
2 mu X plus mu squared.
Using linearity of expectations,
this is broken
down into expected value of X
squared minus the expected
value of two times mu X.
But mu is a constant.
So we can take it outside
the expected value.
And we're left with
2mu expected value
of X plus mu squared.
But remember that mu is just the
same as the expected value
of X. So what we have here is
twice the expected value of X,
squared, plus the expected value
of X, squared, and that
leaves us just minus the
expected value of X, squared.
So we will now move in the
next segment into a few
examples of variance
calculations.